I met you can move out of it figure he
came out swinging with some hot stuff
you know we're aiming for out of this
world over here
[Applause]
it was the knockout round tonight on the
masked singer and things got pretty
heated in the boxing ring hi guys I'm
Charlie O'Keefe and I'm Deidre Behar
pretending to be athletic with these
boxing wraps that I had laying around my
apartment of course we're still home
we're practicing social distancing I'm
home Charlie's home we hope that you're
being safe as well and let's not waste
another minute tonight in the Knockouts
we said goodbye to the kangaroo that's
right the kangaroo gave us to knock out
performances is this evening take a look
[Music]
those were some great performances from
the kangaroo tonight I'm sad to see her
go
I'm truly sad that we won't get any more
but hopefully some more in the future
without further ado guys take a look at
who was behind the kangaroo
[Applause]
with the exception of the first week
that we met the kangaroo and we thought
it was maybe Jordin Sparks I had to give
us credit we did know that this was
Jordan woods from pretty early on in the
season what do you think I definitely
think that the kangaroo performing a
Jordin Sparks song tonight was sick
Louis but listen I know Jordin Sparks
singing the most iconic song of all time
no air like I would recognize that voice
in an instant I think you would too if
you loved that iconic song you know
exactly how it sounds and it obviously
funding put it just sounded very
different but we have been saying Jordan
woods all along so I am happy to see
that we were right yet again talking
patting ourselves virtually on the back
here yeah we're so fun unmasking this
one and actually because we thought it
was Jordan woods so early on when et had
a chance to interview Jordan was at a
completely unrelated event earlier this
year we full-on put her on the spot and
went Lancaster so tonight's reality
check goes to miss Jordan woods no I
love that show so much my sister and I
watch it all the time
I wish I could be on that show no I
actually love the kanger though I've
been watching this season but I'm I'm
late a couple episodes so I need to
catch up
no I wish
I gotta tip my hat to Jordan those
acting skills were on point and it can't
be easy to look someone dead in the eyes
and be like it's not me I don't really
know I'm like what what do you think
listen I told you I think my favorite
thing about the show is when we talk to
people - let me get unmasked and they
have to blatantly and look at us and lie
about being on the show and then we get
to pull the receipts later it's my
favorite thing and hopefully we'll get
to do it eventually for the night angel
who listen I don't know about you but
man I feel like a woman
after that performance tonight take a
look guys a woman
[Applause]
a very empowering performance by who we
keep thinking is kandi Burruss from the
Real Housewives of Atlanta let's talk
about the clue packages tonight they
were so fun kind of a spin on travel on
on going through TSM instead of TSA we
got a little peek inside the night
angels bag so the first thing that stood
out to me was the image of this large
bird which by the way Charlie told me
was an ostrich I thought it was a turkey
the ostrich makes so much sense though
because if you love candy and you
followed her wedding closely like I did
you'd know that her dress her incredible
wedding dress it cost twenty thousand
dollars it was custom made and it
featured a 12-foot train made out
entirely of ostrich feathers that is a
glamorous choice wasn't it wouldn't
expect anything less exactly I would not
expect on a mule awesomer I love it
another thing we saw it was these
luggage tags on the backs of course
which were kind of alluding to things
that not might not necessarily be who we
were guessing so we saw the bag as mine
and boss as two luggage tags the bag is
mine could be the boy is mine hinting to
Monica's famous song listen I don't
think it's Monica I'm sticking Brandie
sorry sorry sorry to brandy including
her there my apologies because that is
an iconic female driven anthem of the
90s yes sticking with candy no not
thinking it's Monica or brandy although
I would like to see them on the show
1,000% they would crush it but candy you
know it's you girl you know it's you
girl and in the second round of
knockouts tonight we saw the astronaut
and the turtle on an oath to you guys
but I love Shawn Mendes and I love the
astronaut and we got both of those
tonight because the pop stars aligned on
the masked singer take a look
[Music]
so Charlie did that make all your pop
star dreams come true yesterday it was
out of this world DJ Fred well of course
out of this world we think it's still
Hunter Hayes the incredible country
singer behind that astronaut mass in his
TSA bag tonight we saw an image of the
White House now if you've been following
Hunter Hayes his career for a long time
you would know that when he was 7 years
old he was invited to perform at the
White House for President Clinton on the
lawn that's a pretty big deal for
anybody let alone a seven-year-old
seven-year-old yeah you have to really
have been a dedicated Hunter Hayes fan
from birth from the beginning
well he's such a talented guy he's got
so many cool critics on his resume
exactly and something else listen I
don't know about you but I love Maury
Povich the paternity test the fights all
of that what I didn't know is that a
young Hunter Hayes went on the Maury
Povich Show to play the accordion which
we saw tonight in his TS a bag as well
this is just this is shocking
the combination of Hunter Hayes Maury
Povich and an accordion performance it's
not something I knew I needed in my life
but I can't tell you how grateful I am
that the masked singer really shined a
light on correct I couldn't agree more
let's make it happen let's get them all
together again 25 20 20 reunion let's do
it
that's all I want well another week of
the turtle means another week of some
beautiful vocals and serenading
performances take a look
[Music]
well I'm you know I'm obsessed with the
turtle I don't apologize for it we
believe it's Jesse McCartney we've said
that from the get-go but what I thought
was really great was that we got to see
a slowed down different version of him
tonight you know don't get me wrong the
high energy choreography and slapping
all the ladies hands in the audience and
all of that showmanship it totally
excites me but he really really proved
if you had any doubts before that this
is a singer a true vocal expert so let's
get right into the clue package I want
to throw out tonight a screw the clue
well I know it's really fun when we do
these because the producers are trying
to make us think one thing but we are
absolutely putting a stop to it so if
you take a look at the bag tag on the
turtles luggage bag it said never keep
open this bag and of course that is like
a an acronym for New Kids on the Block
listen guys this is not a New Kids on
the Block singer 100% Jesse McCartney
and a bonus for you today a second screw
the clue we saw an image of an arrow and
it was even I believe Jenny McCarthy who
was like oh there's an arrow pointing to
one direction as much as I would love to
see a Zayn Malik or a Harry Styles on
this show still calling BS or screwing
the clue that is not someone from one
direction it's our boy Jesse McCartney
yeah and I think it was Kenny who
guessed Niall Horan I mean guys that
arrow was pointing into the wrong
direction for me it is not a member of
One Direction we would know that voice
and I know it's another clue though that
did actually kind of lock it in for
Jesse McCartney for me we saw a judge
gavel well Jesse as we've learned in
previous weeks has appeared and a lot of
shows voiceover works guest our
appearances he guest-starred on Law &
Order the best crime investigation show
of all time so I think the judge gavel
unless he's been to jail or anything we
don't know obviously points to that
guest appearance are you ever not
watching Law & Order no all I love our
crime investigation shows and the
massacre guys all right Charlie O'Keefe
the heart of a 65 year old man who loves
I love it though my other clue I want to
call out really quick is the image of
the Cologne bottle of course Jesse
McCartney fans know he put out his own
Cologne it's called wanted I think I'm
gonna order it while you're at alman
weren't you you'd find it of course
sending it right your way well guys that
is all we have for this week there was a
lot happening in the Smackdown rounds
but Deidre let us know what's happening
next week well very exciting
tomorrow we will be speaking with Jordan
woods aka the kangaroo we're gonna ask
her all the delicious behind-the-scenes
questions of her experience on the
masked singer and you can check that out
tomorrow at 8 p.m. ET online.com and of
course we're gonna show it to you in our
after-show next week which is gonna be
really fun so the mask singer is not
doing a new episode they're doing more
of a catch-up episode and it's gonna be
highlighting all the best moments of the
season and you know what Charlie and I
are here to play as well we want to show
you our favorite moments including ET
original interviews and all of our top
performances and clues and in two weeks
we'll be back with another round of the
smackdowns it is the faceoff round two
and that will include the banana the
Frog Katie and the Rhino I am very
excited to see all four of them now get
up there and compete against one another
we're getting so down to the wire here I
know I asked you this every week but I
just want to check in who is your
current frontrunner listen I've said it
all along I love this night angel she
picks great songs that I listen to
constantly she has sass her costumes
kind of creepy but kind of beautiful I
love everything about it what about you
well I'm really proud I actually
successfully convinced our producer
friend host extraordinaire Leanne
Aguilera to be with me on Team turtle
because turtle Wow yes the light I see
the light this is a person who dances
sings acts gives us everything in every
performance so I'm really still rooting
for the turtle and the Frog okay yeah we
love the Frog - and of course guys keep
sending us your guesses let us know in
the comments Twitter Instagram
everywhere we respond to you guys and we
want to know who you are thinking is
gonna take home that golden Mash trophy
so keep sending us those yes we love
chatting with you thank you so much for
tuning
and another week I'm Deidre Behar aka
Gary tortellini and I'm Charlie O'Keefe
actually we'll see you guys soon
[Music]